someone's been run over by a snow cat
hurry he's been crushed okay done
paramedics to ambulance everybody's on
the way right now listen to me you might
want to get a life flight out here
immediately the neighbors call for help
happened at 8 55 a.m on New Year's Day
and lasted nearly 22 minutes are there
chemicals or other hazards involved no
no no no no no no no no just a lot of
blood it's a hard one the Avenger star
can be heard in the background moaning
in agony awake and barely
yeah there's a lot of blood over here so
you got to get somebody over here
there's ribs look like that maybe
crossed he's got a head wound as well
about 10 minutes in the caller asks for
an update it's hard to give an ETA just
because the the snow on the mountain I
don't know how quick they're able to go
there's breaths are getting shorter so
please you're gonna be all right brother
if you're just paying here to deal with
that you'll be all right we'll get you
out of here hang in there brother
they're coming down right now looks like
yeah that's been wavy now all right
thank you very much Jeremy's back home
after two weeks in the hospital and
there's another development so if you're
here for some sort of Civic cleanup
just know you have a lot of sweeping in
your house too
out of respect for his recovery the
poster promoting Jeremy's Paramount Plus
show mayor of Kingstown has been
adjusted the blood cuts and injuries on
the actor's face have been softened
now to another 9-1-1 call after Lisa
Marie Presley went into cardiac arrest
her panicked housekeeper can be heard
trying to guide emergency workers what's
the address to emergencies
right yes but the closest Street on the
corner is a province Drive I don't know
which Providence well this is yes
ma'am is there someone else there with
you right now at this point a man
believed to be Lisa Marie's ex-husband
Danny Keough takes over the call Hey sir
listen Paramus already on the way so
that they need to get in there uh no
there's a security gate on the
neighborhood but still just let him
through I have no idea where they're at
right now
I think they're here according to a
report Lisa Marie's heart stopped a
second time after she was hospitalized
but because of her condition her family
had already ordered doctors not to
resuscitate her today at Graceland Lisa
Marie's final resting place was being
prepared in the backyard of the estate
she'll be buried next to her son
Benjamin and just a few feet away from
her beloved father
[Music]
at least we honored Sunday at Graceland
with a public celebration of life
[Music]